نحن داخل المطار مروي الدولي هذا المطار
الذي يشاهد اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني من خلف
مباشره هذا هو برج المراقبه الذي تعرض
فيما يبدو الى اضرار جسيمه نتيجه هذه
المواجهات المسلحه التي شهدها هذا المطار
وخلفت اعداد كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
بطبيعه الحال ولكن لا ندري اعداد هؤلاء
القتلى والجرحى بطبيعه الحال هذه طبعا كل
تفاصيل البنايات الملحقه بهذا المطار
اصابها الضرر بشكل كبير خاصه كثير من
المركبات العسكريه اصابها الضرر كان هناك
جنود كثيرون يعني يتقاتلون في هذه الساحه
كل تفاصيل المشهد يشير الى ان المكان قد
شهد يعني اشتباكات
عنيفه استخدمت فيها كل الاسلحه تقريبا بكل
انواعها وجود العنا
تنتمي الى الجيش السوداني بهذه الكثافه
وهذا الانفجار داخل داخل المطاط ويحوي
باضافه الى مطار
مطار مدني هناك ايضا قاعده عسكريه تلاحظون
حجم الدمار هذا هو هذه اسوار
زجاجيه لاحدى الصالات هذه الصاله المغادره
ربما ما حدث هنا
يشير الى ان ما حدث لم يكن سهلا
رسم ملامح واقع جديد على هذا المكان قال
الجيش السوداني ان القوات الدعم السريع
قبل ان ينسحب عمودت على تدمير البنى
التحتيه بالنسبه للمطار حسب يعني اتهامات
للناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني طبعا
بهذا بهذه التفاصيل وبهذا المشهد لا احد
يستطيع ان يتكهن كيف يمكن ان يعود هذا
المطار من
اذا الطلقات وكل التفاصيل هنا ترسم شكل من
اشكال الدمار دمار كبير طبعا يحتاج هذا
المطار الى ايام وبجهود الى يعني جهود
كبيره في الواقع حتى يعود من جديد حتى
يعود من جديد
للملاحه الجويه اذن اسامه سيد احمد كنا
معكم من داخل مطار مروي الدولي من مدينه
مروي في شمال السودان